washington is actively attempting to
prevent iran from buying any coronavirus
vaccines that's the claim being made by
the chief of iran central bank
echoing earlier remarks made by the
country's foreign minister
kovid19 vaccines have to be purchased
through the official channels of the
world health organization
but all payment methods have been
blocked by the inhumane embargoes of the
us government
more than 50 000 iranians have died
during the pandemic with over a million
confirmed infections it is the worst hit
country in the middle east
so let's look at how sanctions might be
affecting that situation
the trump administration slapped
restrictions on iran's financial system
part of its maximum pressure campaign
these target iranian individuals and
banks as well as
foreign entities working with iran's
central bank transactions for medical
supplies
can be exempted but need the u.s
treasury's approval
we've asked the u.s treasury to comment
on iranian allegations u.s sanctions are
preventing access to a covered vaccine
in the meantime caveathibia political
scientist and author of iranian origin
shared his thoughts on the situation the
sanctions are primarily you know
financial and trade in nature
but they they basically affect all
aspects of the iranian economy have
serious
ripple effects on the health sector the
u.s is doing whatever it can to
undermine iran's ability to procure the
necessary medical
devices and in this case the vaccines
that
are on the horizon
case in point is pressuring the
government
of south korea not to unfreeze
the billions of dollars of the iranian
asset
that iran needs in order to
purchase you know millions of doses of
vaccine by causing all these
restrictions you're also amputating the
global effort to combat
this disease so if the u.s is not
hypocritical and has an ioda of
humanitarian concern for iran it would
not take such drastic actions that
directly affect
the well-being of millions of iranians
you